how's it going citizens of the reject nation
john here for a solo movie reaction thank you for
joining me we're going to watch pray the fifth
film in the predator standalone franchise
uh i'm very excited for this really enjoyed
the trailers really excited to see how this
take plays out i love the time and place they've
chosen to set it in so we'll see obviously it's
hard to top the original predator dylan is one
of my all-time favorite movie meme moments and
i got love for predators as well and i could
never forget avp the movie that unfortunately
taught me in the heat of a trivia match uh the
difference between the arctic and antarctica
so that's the thing but anyhow greg and i were
originally going to check this out together and
unfortunately the vid diesel caught up with us and
we also had a round of press interviews to do with
the cast director and producer so he unfortunately
had to go off ahead of me so i am catching up now
but if you haven't seen those interviews please
go give them a look greg did an excellent job
and actually after shooting all of this we were
given the opportunity to cover the red carpet
premiere for prey do some interviews there meet
the actual cast and crew in person it was a very
very cool experience so if you want to check some
of that out it's on the channel as well so check
those out if you haven't seen those and as always
if you could leave a like on this video that would
help out a lot as well as just a comment including
your thoughts on the movie or anything else you
want to talk about subscribe hit that notification
bell to get notified every single time something
interesting comes out on the channel you will
be informed and if you'd like to get the full
experience go beyond the reaction highlights you
can come on over to our patreon page patreon.com
the real rejects that's where you can sync up with
your own copy enjoy the full movie alongside me
or a bunch of other shows and movies that we have
exclusive reaction highlights as well as watch
alongs for last but not least cannot forget
the folks over at prepper for handling these
highlights cutting them down making them look all
nice for you guys very much appreciate them and uh
yeah without further ado
man let's watch us some pray
a long time ago it is said a monster came here
okay it's like a folk tale
oh
i wonder just how many reactions the
first time people see the dog they go oh
blue on those flowers really pops huh
it's freaking sound effects man
you want to go out to one of those
axe throwing ranges such a satisfying sound
oh
no
at least it's just a tail though
yeah you knew that wasn't
the ordinary thunderstorm
i remember when father told me i was ready for
katan went up into the hills the rain was bad
everything was wet we crawled through
the mud my bowstring got ruined
ah yeah you were sleeping now you're gonna have
to cross the river to get it it's time i'm ready
for my katamia you want to hunt something that's
hunting you uh-huh there's a theme for you i guess
that is the true battle is if you can outwit
something that's coming for you specifically
attention to detail is awesome
trained him well it's easy he's smart
not every smart creature is easy to train
like you most likely
your father left you that to cut bread
root with you almost got a deer with it
why do you want to hunt because
you all think that i can't
yeah that's fair in this wind he
brings home a red tail of course
meanwhile this dude is just cruising
around looking for a place to
uh park game is a foot each little predator
at least thus far like each little predator
appearance has been really well like spaced
out i keep getting lulled into just like
the life on display hina a lion
he took bowie you got to find him
who invited you we won't be
gone long enough need to cook
hey she tracks well if we find pouya
alive she knows medicine yeah bro
oh
a fighter snake i don't care
as that was that was a very clever [__]
so cool i love the the rhythm with
which they're depicting all these things
like how resourceful they are and how like
synchronized they are tommy wants to stay and hunt
let's go i'm coming with you i can't handle the
life it's not just the world i've got this we
don't have time to waste talking we need to
get him home yeah quiet lois men are talking
so many beautiful shots in this movie like
jeez okay the cold is good the medicine slows
his blood if he gets warm he'll bleed out hey
do you want him to be comfortable or alive mia
ah you knew that was coming pete snake's been
waiting there all day like i got one left in me
one good death rattle
oh look it could be bear tracks maybe but that's a
big bear and why was it on its hind legs and what
skin's a snake like that we need to keep moving
no i have to warn my brother pakka go with there
what do i gotta go with her why'd you come
back i found tracks and they were huge i'm
not frightened by a bear i don't think it was a
bear or whatever it was we're in the cat's den now
we have to deal with the first now's your shot
it'll think it's hunting us a hunter doesn't eat
he hunts like a beer all night we could stock
the forest all night and not find anything too
will bait it then i'll lead the cat to you
it's time you cut them here and the line comes
you tell that thing this is as far as you
go no more this is it as far as you go
no more this is it like each time i'm afraid it's
gonna go that way like i'm like okay like i like
their relationship so far which is also why i'm
afraid he's about to get murked like right now
you've never faced a lion this mouth full of
teeth like arrows ready to tear your flesh
when your brother comes back he and
i will find the lion and kill him
this is a good jump scare oh cool oh damn
what a shot damn that is that is a lion
jesus man the shots
your brother carried you home you think
the reason for kotamiya is to prove
you can hunt but there's
only one reason to survive
that's the sage way of looking at that
actually the hunt isn't the full picture
jesus we did it we didn't do it what do you
think left those tracks and before i fell i saw
lightning in the church there's something
else okay well i'll hunt alone if i have to
you can't you're right we didn't do it i did
you tried it you just you couldn't bring
it home oh war chief gonna have his day
if they don't see
we'll show them
i wonder how they lit this movie like a lot of
this looks really really natural which i guess
has become sort of a meme lately but it looks
really great here it looks really beautiful
nice nice match cut this aerial shots and these
landscape shots like it feels like you're watching
some kind of like like a ken burns documentary
crashed into like a nature special or something
owner oh i gotta check the
race this movie rated r for goo
that's a big foot
wow
dang
a little green in his teeth
her teeth there too
freaking squaring off
don't go no don't don't oh
so mortal kombat of you bro jesus pray
is a really good title for this movie
like so much food chaining all around
yes
oh cool
does that mean we're gonna get
like an elaborate dog hunting scene
chew stick gotta get your oral hygiene
what national park do they shoot
this in or was it just canada
brutal fairy metal
he's a scout too he's collecting belt loops
ah so cool that's so awesome
ugh yeah some didn't look right
ugh
my stogy
i know i left that cigar here somewhere
oh no of course
this looks like it was fun to shoot
uh
it's like pita in the hunger games
with the the cake frosting blending in
huh
hey
well done this movie is a very cool
sound design expressive sound design
and now she's covered in mud clever
sorry it took me it took me a second
okay less covered in mud
this dog is really good too like i call them
animal actors i'm like in this case i'm like yeah
he's a very good boy
whoa there's a scar and a half
oh
ah [__] and now it becomes the edge
who's afraid of the bear now this bear's
been here this whole time like i heard
what you said you was afraid of
a barrel jews afraid of a bear
i i have a feeling a lot of people are gonna be
sitting there going as long as the dog's okay
you can massacre as many
rabbits bears buffalo whatever
oh my god
oh damn oh he caught up holy [__]
let that be a lesson to you
look at that
that is pretty freaking metal jesus christ
so much for that camo boy looking for you
your brother sent us to bring you
home i saw what left those tracks
i couldn't see it until it was covered in
blood but it looked like like a moot beats
it fought and killed a bear with its hands easily
how come it didn't kill you thanks thanks bro
jesus you want to live
there's something else
i like to think the predator collects this
footage and then does like silly voice overs
stupid possums don't even believe that
possum's dead though you know how they are
wow oh
come on you got a clever trick up your
sleeve oh no gotta conserve those darts man
that faceplate holy [__]
oh
taking heads man
yeah you want to talk battle cries i really am
enjoying the way that they're using the cloaking
jesus
is that what it sounds like
to be in the predator's helmet
no no no no no
no it's close
yeah i was going to say you can't outrun predators
spray
oh chekhov's bear trap god dammit
are they french
oh you better be careful with that dog
yeah in the most [__] wasteful way possible it's
a great gag too because at first you're like would
predator do that and you're like oh wait maybe
not nope that's just us i think this creature
is a hunter if you were smart you would help
us tell us something like the last sacred point
there's something about a savage oh
no that's all how do they have him too
geez
it's like raiders that's what you went
out after it's what you were tracking yes
and that's what you chose for good dummy
great user perspectives man
it's a great way to play into like
the slasher movie quality it's coming
he's coming for us no it doesn't
want paid it doesn't hunt that way
before the trappers captured me it saw me
and then left i didn't think i was a threat
oh see you're not a mary sue
your plan the tree you weakened it you had it nadu
oh you can see what i made he always had i don't
know that this thing can be killed the lion though
they did it together if it bleeds we can kill
snuck it right in there dude but like ah
perfect camper on that scene oh my god
ah that's so freaking cool
bro sorry good effort
oh
remember old guns remember muskets
remember reload time
oh
get the head [__] he's like yeah
it's a good kill it's a good kill
the
losing his leg to be free wait not
what are you doing nader nada stop huh
i'll get sweaty
parkour
these guys are all really well cast like they
feel like they're out of a different time
yes this will go well keep on
watching the show's about to begin
oh [__]
badass this is a really cool movie man this
is really cool like they still got to stick
the landing but so far like it's nice to have
like a really punchy solid predator movie now
oh god way to shoot this action too oh
jesus
oh
oh jesus
i swear the little hatchet
with the the rope on it just
coolest freaking tweak
oh god well done with the focus like
hide them out of sight oh ow ooh
and i'll show you how to use it
this guy looks kind of like the geico cave
man take the ball and put it in the garden
watch
ah pull that back and it will fire that's all
yeah you need i don't know it'll create a spark
what's easy shut up and take
your medicine i'm freezing cold
are you still a threat oh my god yes possum
and the predator surveyed the wreckage with the
coldest blue outlook as if to say that he is
one and the same with the thermal readout on his
screen that with which he sees all of life jesus
props to represent a well-timed jesus between
predator and and naru and the focusrack like
you're so close
no though no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no
oh geez that was that was close still
oh and get what you got to think for masks my guy
no hey
jeez
ah cheater not so tough when you're invisible this
is as far as i go no this is it no oh no no no no
there's the white hot in her eyes
not going out without a fight though oh
they're really great at
emphasizing things with sound
like the way they framed that like
you knew his moment was nigh but like
like they're really good at sort
of arresting you in the moment with
an interesting sound choice or something like that
we keep watching all this time
you really are the best boy oh my dudes back of
course this guy's the one who made it jesus christ
no
that's one fierce slap bracelet
this guy's eyes are just always
about to pop right out of his head
oh that's twisted oh no you think
that i'm not a hunter like you
oh that is what makes me dangerous
hey go see you coming you
can't see but i'm killing you
excuse me
oh
that can't be i mean are you doing okay
how much of your brain is left after that
you want your helmet how many abs does he have
she that i don't know you know predator
you don't need to gender the
predator oh nice oh that was awesome
love that it's that touch with
the glowing translucent blood
oh take that bro
oh he's mad now he's very
mad he underestimated you
now he's actually trying
oh [__]
oh jesus oh jesus no
oh
yes hog time
think i give a [__] about some sinkhole this
is as far as you go no more this is it this is it
yep
yes
oh my god you earned that
i told you guys it was bigger than a bear
so cool
the way they painted that on her face like
i don't know i feel like that could easily
look silly but it it does look convincing
like such a literal contrast to when tommy
comes back with the nice man hell yeah oh
god that was that was very cool that flew
by too like it was really really tight
things that are paced well and use their style
to enhance every little emotional nuancer tight
i love that the actual like cave painted
predator god well done i gotta say i mean
as much as the opening title sequences
is something that i love you know a good
interesting opening title i do appreciate
that people throw down for these you know
creative end credit sequences as
well those are for people like me
and again man the title prey
like it's perfect oh oh oh
the predator will return for the comanche nation
wow see that's cool too because it i think greg
brought this up in the uh interview too is like
as much as these are exploitation movies like
this this does feel very earnest in the way that
it portrays the comanche and and the way that it
uses their sort of way of life as the setting
and the sort of time and place this is a really
nice blend between something that yeah feels
authentic to the time i i'm no expert on you know
uh native american history or anything like
that but yeah just like the way that it took
time to observe those things and then also
do a bunch of you know crazy predator [__]
like is really really well balanced
and pitched and conceived hey adi
i should have known yeah amalgamated dynamics
they do a lot of the predator stuff back in
the old days at uh fangoria we went there we
visited we did a blood and guts episode about
it all right i think we are we are good on all
the different credit scenes that there could be
i'm going to take the risk and uh we are going to
hop into the review uh yeah all right man i mean
yeah i mean if you've been here with me this whole
time or for the reaction highlights or whatever
uh i mean it's i think it's pretty evident that
i quite enjoyed this movie and uh you know i mean
when we did the trailer reactions at the outset
i was reasonably optimistic i mean you know as
everyone up until this point has clarified and you
know reiterated the predator franchises of varying
quality um but you know the promise of you know
something a little more simple and a little more
straightforward and a little more back to basics
for predator seemed uh you know like a good one
and that's a choice i appreciate in general you
know when you take something that is you know
science fiction heavy or very futuristic
or that relies on a certain amount of like
futuristic technology or weaponry or things like
that when you take you know that idea and then
you transplant it into a time that's much more
rudimentary or analog or just you know based on
the elements and on nature uh i feel like that can
temper the science fiction in a really rewarding
way that forces you know the filmmakers to get a
little clever like it's not the same kind of thing
but like when uh you know going from watching like
the mcu and agents of shield then to checking out
agent carter uh was like a really nice breath of
fresh air because while agent carter still had
like a lot of the sci-fi context and you know uh
scenarios and mcguffins and whatever it was often
tempered by the fact that we were in like the 30s
and 40s very different from this time and place
but a similar kind of again the word i keep going
for is tempering of the fact that yes like you're
not in the future it's not spaceships nobody has
like machine guns like the weapons that you have
are either made out of again found objects wood
and string or else they're like very rudimentary
guns for the most part and that goes to highlight
in a situation like this too i think especially
the the idea that it's not the weapon you know
so much as it is the wielder the hunter you
know the predator itself and uh trusting dan
trachtenberg from things like 10 cloverfield
lane and just again the interesting hook of this
historical fiction period piece crashed into you
know something that looks pretty familiar like a
predator movie yeah i had a lot of optimism coming
into this but um i was just constantly surprised
at every turn by just how much care and how much
um just attention to detail in almost every
regard seemed to have gone into this movie like
you know it it would have been pretty easy i
think to make this relatively speaking to make
this a satisfying cool movie but i guess pretty
easy is probably the wrong phrase all things
considered but you know i feel like they could
have easily made a pretty good predator movie
that wasn't necessarily a good movie
whereas here i think it manages to be
both and as much as i like predators i feel like
that might be what holds that movie back uh from
certain people's like full enthusiasm is like
yeah as a movie it might not be that great as a
predator movie is pretty cool but yeah this movie
i think manages very successfully to be both and
i would happily like have this movie kind of like
separated in some kind of you know d fusion in a
fission machine or something like that and i would
probably still watch both movies i would probably
just watch like the silent film about predator
tracking through the woods and you know the the
comanche movie about this girl coming of age and
going on you know this spiritual rite of passage
i really gotta kind of commend everyone involved
for helping it sort of transcend that into being
you know not more than it needs to be but
like really really conscientiously and
really thoughtfully what it needs to be and it
does bring elements that you don't necessarily
need in a predator movie but i think really help
this movie and i mean i think uh as i think greg
said this in his in his interviews with the
cast you know this he said this was the most
he had cared about a character in the predator
franchise i mean obviously everyone loves arnold
dutch but uh yeah i mean they give you this
juxtaposition of the predator doing its
its hunter thing you know traversing the galaxy
searching for you know to steal the it word of
a couple years ago the apex predator of whatever
ecosystem he's in squaring off with that you know
creature whatever it may be and bringing back that
head as a trophy and then on the other side of
that you have you know this young budding warrior
who wants to prove her salt but is having trouble
with that and yeah you you have this very sort of
thoughtful and and um i don't know very natural
kind of depiction it would seem of life in this
comanche camp and you know again the uh what they
call it the katamiya uh i hope i'm saying that
right this sort of com the the rite of passage
the coming of age ritual in which you sort of
pick your uh you know the predator or yeah again
the themes of prey and predator are so like well
laced into like every scene of this movie just
the way different creatures and people and and all
different points on the food chain kind of occupy
both of those roles in different points in time
so i'm probably going to say the words predator
and prey a lot in here um but yeah you know you
you have your sort of white whale that you need
to go out and slay as part of this coming-of-age
mission and i liked the nuances that came of that
especially with the mom and the brother uh
you know the way she she kind of uh checks
naru uh in the middle point of the movie where
you know uh tabe has to bring her back uh and
she says you know like it's not about
hunting it's not about proving yourself
as a hunter necessarily it's about surviving
and it is an interesting thing i mean it's
not not comforting i'm sure to hear that because
you know you gotta achieve but uh this this movie
again like around every corner kept impressing
me with the things it chose to embellish
in spite of how simple certain aspects of it
are it's a simple journey in a sense for this
character in terms of a story you know she wants
to prove herself to her tribe and her family
and she wants to be taken seriously and she wants
to prove to herself that she has the ability
to you know follow her instincts for tracking and
for hunting and you know to serve the tribe in
that way and to be recognized for those skills
not just the skills of medicine but but two
even still not like issuing those either by the
end like as a character journey i thought they did
really nicely to sort of bring her full circle
by the end you know to bring her to a sort of
completion or to like a next uh iteration you know
in her growth and and her journey but yeah like to
show somebody who has a whole lot of potential at
the outset who has natural skills and abilities
but who needs to hone them and who needs to
mature in the face of the elements and in the face
of all the interconnecting concerns of a hunt and
you know the tribe ecosystem just the ecosystem of
the land around and two i mean the way the movie
utilizes the elements as its own sort of natural
but still predatory force is really well engaged
and is something that i think is is another one
of those primal aspects that you know even if
you're not used to spending a lot of time outdoors
you know you can still relate to you know
if you were thrust into that situation
you would have these things just probably just
as many things at your disposal so like there
is something innate about that that i think too
they use very nicely to their advantage and as a
foil just as much as it is sort of an asset to the
characters and i mean props to the entire cast but
especially to amber mid thunder and dakota beavers
as well for just like really throwing themselves
full-heartedly it appears into these roles and
into you know both the acting side of it but also
the physical side of it just like getting out into
the elements and you know uh doing this combat and
and writing and and you know digging around in the
muck and the mud and everything like really really
challenging i would imagine to be on set for
but also i mean i just thought they they really
committed and really brought the authenticity and
and sold the whole thing wonderfully again they
just put so much more care and effort than they
had to and i really really loved that because
again it's both in the writing like the dialogue
and the the story at hand isn't like the most
crazy intricate deep thing but the combination of
the dialogue and the this character journey they
created combined with the performances i
think just really made this come to life
in a way that like really makes it easy to sink
into perspectives and that's on the filmmaking
too i mean hats off to dan trachtenberg's
direction because the way the movie shifts
between perspectives and i mean i'm talking like
character perspectives but sometimes you're in
the predator's perspective sometimes you're in the
perspective of just animals and things like that
and the way the camera sometimes even glides
you between those things in the same shot uh
with a rack of focus or a subtle you know angle
shift or whatever a subtle motion like there's
so many great really solid choices and there are
cool shots and [__] and there's like a bunch
of stuff that's really striking but all that
stuff is really well chosen i feel like like
this is a great example again of like a really
solidly directed movie that has like a bunch of
cool stuff in it but it's like really concerned
on just selling and enhancing and embellishing
the most important aspects which in this are
you know your characters to make sure that you
actually care about what's going on so it's not
just a bloodbath and then yeah like paying homage
to and giving us those like nerdy fan moments
that we want to see of the predator and i
i liked very much the way that they built
the predator up over the course of the movie
and these little appearances you know the ship
goes by and intermingling that with folk tales
and things like that i i forget the the certain
names she says at one point when she's describing
you know what she saw to the other guys uh who
you know she she's hunting with and and who are
you know sort of like keeping an eye on her while
tommy's out looking for her and and uh you know
she says it like looks like this mythical creature
and you know there's like the firebird myth
uh that that i think they named check at one point
um you know like and i'm no expert on these things
so i cannot like reiterate them for you here and
now off the dome um but yeah like the way that
they played that into you know folklore and sort
of spiritual belief and then you know even though
we know it's not quite that it kind of is and
like it's those little philosophical flourishes
too that i think are kind of nice because
yeah like it is her katamia eventually like
whether you like it or not you know like she is
the one who kind of notices and knows to take
the predator seriously and and two like i love the
theme they use of of it not seeing her as a threat
and it's you know i mean anytime you have uh a
female lead and a movie like this that's known for
like macho dudely characters i feel like people
get up in arms about wokeness and primary suit but
i thought they made like a really great wonderful
character journey in a physical sense like not
only are you watching you know her um you know her
her self-worth improvement and we're watching her
you know persevere and use you know the best
of her knowledge and instincts but we watch
her really have to learn and observe and it is in
that sense of you know using that underestimation
as an asset like it doesn't see me as a threat
but that's how what makes me threatening now is
because i've been able to observe like you watch
the predator tracking and stuff throughout the
movie and nadu is kind of doing that too and even
in that sense you kind of have like this this sort
of like polar sort of attraction that leads them
together through the action of the story and two
i thought they had clever takes on that theme of
invisibility of cloaking yourself to avoid i mean
literally usually the predator's you know thermal
vision but doing that on multiple levels where
it's like yeah they have a means of of you know
becoming invisible by ingesting the the orange
tootsie of the flower uh but also you know she has
that added layer at least for for naru where it's
you know he doesn't see me because he's not
concerned with me and i thought the way that they
you know utilized that i'll talk about that
a little bit more in a bit but the way that
they utilized that i thought was was a nice
two-fold that almost like helped that they
they homaged the whole getting caked in mud thing
without actually having to use that because like
that's the one thing about like predators is like
adrien brody at one point pretty much just does
the dutch and covers himself in mud and like it's
cool and all that but i thought here like they
they came up with ways to use that but as both
a theme and a physical phenomenon that's not the
exact same thing so just like props for for like
easter egging and expounding on that you know
yeah and i mean even the predator like you know
i like to that this is i mean this is you know
300 odd years an hour past currently and uh you
know i don't have the best grip on like every
i can't pinpoint every predator movie on the
timeline but in setting this beforehand uh you
know i feel like it also gives you this kind of
interesting view on like because the predator
doesn't speak you can kind of ascribe any sort of
other story detail headcanon you want to it so in
a way it's almost like this predator is on its
own sort of journey of at least conquest perhaps
some kind of you know coming of age or rite of
passage for uh you know that species of predators
also just a sidebar but i love the sort of tweaked
design they went with for the predator i mean
that's obviously very much akin to the designs
that have come before or that will come in the
future um but yeah with the slightly more narrow
face and again that bone plate sort of giving it
again a slightly more tribal and a slightly more
primitive uh aesthetic to sort of match again
being so far removed in time or being so far
back in the past like i thought that was again
subtle tweaks um and i think they're they're i
mean there are definitely like gadgets and guns
and stuff like that that are like direct easter
eggs from other predator movies but i thought the
design choice here was was really cool and really
suited again without being a direct overhaul just
the aesthetic of the movie at hand but even
so like i thought that was complimentary
and there were so many things that had these
like dual components or that would you know be
important at one point or come up at one
point and then come back whether it be like
the sinkhole uh at first being this like major
obstacle for nadu to you know figure her way
out of and then later to come back and use as
part of her ultimate you know finishing move
um but yeah like all that stuff like even running
into the trappers and sort of seeing two i love
that like that that switcheroo like you see
this field full of decimated buffalo or bison
or whatever and you think to yourself like oh
my god you know predators really laying it down
but then the further you get and the more you
realize like but they couldn't have been like
that threatening right like they're not the apex
predators of the region they're not you know the
bears or the wolves or the snakes or whatever so
yeah i love that switcheroo of like the cigar as
a sort of not mcguffin but just yeah like a sign
a harbinger of like oh no no it's not what you
think and i feel like that's something that you
know it's like i would have almost missed that
um but yeah like having even that come around is
like okay you know there's monstrousness within
us and there's that sort of primal like when your
back's up against the wall you just have to you
know either fight or die in this situation
if you're up against the predator there's
pretty much two choices um but yeah like the
the way that they kind of constructed this very
uh naturally unfolding journey they're you know
out uh there's a lion in the area it slashed up
one of their uh you know tribes people and
they gotta go you know find the lion and you
know neutralize it and bring it back and kind
of restore order to the food chain of the area
and then yeah that kind of uh kind of yeah just
like intersecting with this predators just sort
of uh walkabout of you know supremacy of just
you know like taking on all the greatest uh you
know beasts in the area and whatnot and they just
happen to stumble upon these guys but even so like
i really enjoyed again i've used the word probably
tangibility a lot i like the tangibility of this
quite a bit because you know you really do feel
like you are you feel the the land you feel
that some of the time that it takes to get places
and the distance and again like i said this before
it's like you know 10 cloverfield lane does so
much with a tight confined space in this movie
obviously you're outdoors for pretty much all of
it unless you're you know inside a hut or a tp or
something so uh you know you ring a lot of i guess
agoraphobia out of that and claustrophobia because
of you know the things that can be lurking between
trees and i thought they did a really nice job too
in this movie of using the predator's cloaking
ability as sort of its own presence like for so
much of the movie even though you know what's
coming i feel like the cloaking mechanism is
especially useful for something like this because
you can only do so many flybys before you have to
have an actual like no predator appearance and
i thought the way that they used the stealth
especially for when he's you know like quietly
observing things like i would be curious to go
back and look through this and see like are there
more times where you can see him lurking than you
even realize um but yeah like the way that they
used that and the way that in the different you
know altercations the different fights and things
like it was spark and you would see like patches
and stuff like that like i thought that was a
really just sort of sinister and really cool
looking motif that again you know it it goes
to show that while that's like a major asset
while the predator does have like you know so
many abilities to just make the fight like unfair
you know like he's he's got like tracking and
and you know he can pinpoint targets and and
all that other stuff and you know he's got
these blades and you know it's things like
that that helped kind of even the playing field
and make it feel like yeah you know this is
a an alien being from an advanced race engineer to
hunt and kill but you know i believe that part of
part of the point of doing that and part of maybe
even the thrill if you want to ascribe such a you
know emotional value to a predator is the risk you
know is the danger factor is like what would be
the point if not to say that you brought back the
skull of something particularly dangerous and i i
love the the choice to set this in the comanche
nation to set this among people who live off the
land and who you know really know how to make
everything you need to survive out of everything
that is just kind of here now and doesn't need uh
you know it's like either the figuring out is in
you know like making the gurney like i love that
scene where she's applying the ointments and they
are you know taking bits and pieces and they're
making this gurney and they are doing it like
clockwork because they have to and it's like you
can see how uh tabe is you know in his position
and i loved again like i called out in the
reactions like i really enjoyed that they made him
a real nuanced character that you know does
seem to care for his sister he has his own pride
but he does stick up for her and he does support
her especially as the rest of the you know
tribe that they're with is you know laughing
at her and belittling her and whatever else
um you know i really enjoyed their relationship
together and i like that you're like yeah he is
you know an instrumental part of it and then you
have that flipperoo or is that the you know when
they do the lion hunt you know it's her plan and
he puts his faith in her and she is instrumental
in getting it done which he ultimately admits to
later but she didn't yeah fully bring it home he
needed to complete that whereas at the end it's
the reverse it's like he is able to help he's
able to get her that critical window but she's
the one who over the course of this went out and
looked for this creature and observed its habits
and its fight style and and how it hunts and all
that stuff like she gets this this fascinatingly
like you know hyper physical and fight or flight
but also like very oddly kind of intimate glimpse
at how this creature works and i think again that
linchpin and i know uh you know i don't know
if he saw her as a threat at one point i guess
you could argue like why didn't he just kill
her anyway but i liked that motif and i liked
giving the predator a bit of agency because
like the body language i thought was really
great like i really loved the blend of i'm
sure there's a lot of cg shots but i also
really got the sense of the actor in the suit
you know bringing some of that slasher movie
personality um you know i mean the noise and the
articulation of the you know face and the mask or
you know puppeteering all the combination of
that movie magic brings that to life but two
just the thought that the predator might be able
to make a choice like that make a decision like
that regarding its hunt and then you know have
that come back around like that red as a true
thing to me that you might encounter just out
in the wild in the sort of natural order of a
you know hostile food chain so yeah like this
this was just an experience where again like the
music like i i really appreciated that too like
i thought they did nicely to ground the music
in you know like there's certain flavors that
i'm sure like trophy by this point that you
expect to hear in a native american setting no
matter what that is uh you expect to hear like
drums or flutes and things like that or certain
vocalizations and there is that and and there
is i think tasteful use of that but there are also
just period-appropriate instruments and then where
appropriate it seems as well certain like synth
flourishes and yeah i just like it i thought they
really expressively used the music in a way that
felt again very natural and and sort of tangible
even though it is you know part of the more
heightened aspect of movie magic um uh but yeah
like the sound effects uh especially like that
that tomahawk hitting the wood each time and that
that you know the tomahawk with the rope on it
you know like great great call it reminded me of
i don't know what that martial art is called but
you know where you have like the dagger on the end
of the the rope um yeah just just like this had
so many great elements that like are befitting of
the cool fun [__] you want from and you know
predator movies or exploitation movies they're fun
action horror you know adventures in their own way
but they're also exploitation movies and so you
have those exploitable elements but you also have
an earnest story and also an earnest depiction of
its you know subjects in you know the sort of
culture the comanche nation that they chose to
sort of center the the story around and to sort
of build their characters out of like that was
something that i was very curious about going
into this because obviously you see like it's
an indigenous cast for the most part uh pretty
much completely um and and you know there are
people uh working behind the scenes producers and
whatnot who are uh of comanche uh descent as well
as you know uh various other indigenous cultures
but it's one of those things where you see it and
you're like ah this could easily just be like a
nifty idea that they're not gonna really dive into
at all that is just gonna be kind of a skin to lay
over top of this to make it seem like it's fresh
um yeah there are a lot of ways that this could
have been cynical or trite but i thought they
really too while it's not like a deep historical
dive into you know the nuances of comanche life
uh it does take time to observe that though like
when you're in the camp you know it lets you drink
in those details and it seems like they really did
just kind of build what appears to be an actual
camp and just kind of let life unfold there as it
might have and the way they chose to capture that
just felt very again observant and compassionate
and you know very informed by something authentic
you know like it seemed like they really cared
to make this life feel real and tangible and
and as well informed by you know some actual
history as possible so yeah like even if it's
not the quote-unquote point i was really happy to
see that they didn't just use it as just kind of
like oh it's a neat you know kind of uh a gimmick
i guess that's it it wasn't a gimmick for this
movie it was very very much ingrained in the heart
and soul and the core story of this and so that's
something that like again i i was a little worried
they might fumble but they they very much did not
and you have really beautiful cinematography
with really beautiful lighting that really
puts you in the setting and then two uh like i i
cannot i'm really excited to watch the comanche
dub of this because i mean i i don't know i i
love seeing things like this that very naturally
kind of lend a platform and very naturally kind of
give people a reason to sort of take an interest
in history or a different culture or whatever um
and yeah so like i'm really excited to watch uh
the dub and just sort of take it in that way but
i love the way that they too kind of use a certain
level of like there's dialogue obviously it drives
a lot of the story uh you know of the personal
journey uh journey of naru and her you know close
uh you know her brother and her her tribe and
all that stuff but there's so much of this movie
that is just about body language and physicality
and there is a lot of the story that could be told
without words you know and so i like too that even
uh language can be a barrier and can represent
sort of um i don't know the the difference between
winding up predator or prey in a certain situation
uh you know ostensibly the guy who is like the one
vaguely sympathetic dude with the french camp
with the trappers you know it's like i guess he
could have spoken to tabe but like you know their
ability and willingness to communicate in that
moment you know it's like you you hear french and
they don't subtitle it so you're like you're kept
on the outside and that too like i think during
the trailer we had theorized that these would be
like you know english speaking settlers of some
sort um but i love that choice too because that's
another thing that makes you go like oh wait a
minute so let me figure out where exactly in the
in the plains we are and let me go crack a history
book again because that's kind of interesting
um but also yeah like it creates again another
barrier that uh puts you uh sets you uneasy you
know it's uh yeah it's it's another way in which
you could you know like lose that critical edge in
being able to you know scrape out of a situation
or avoid you know some kind of ill fate and i mean
they are like like a pretty horrible bunch for
the most part so it does make for a very sort of
satisfying slashery kind of act three when they're
all getting hacked up and they tie them to the
you know big stump and they you know are using
them as baits but uh yeah like watching just
the whole thing crescendo into some really cool
action sequences with again the requisite amounts
of like gore and viscera and like really
kind of cringe inducing stomach churning
gags but again it's not just gor gorgorg or gore
like there is a good amount of blood but like
there's that one shot where they cut really wide
and it's the spray out in the field i thought that
was really striking or you know when they when he
does the thing with the snake uh you know you see
it through the back of the the camouflage
so like there are clever ways of not quite
showing you or not showing you in certain moments
that again just speak to a certain level of like
sophistication i feel like in the direction i
feel like you know you can approach something
like this with a certain amount of uh gusto and a
certain amount of sort of abandon but also i think
you know like clever uses of restraint or clever
kind of turns of the screw on a certain detail
or whatever can just make all the difference
and so yeah this is one of those movies that
that manages to kind of transcend what it is by
just doing what it's trying to do really well and
with a ton of consideration and with the right
amount of compassion and again like it's a really
great movie at showcasing perspectives just as
much as it is at building up horror and putting
you like right into the adrenaline rush of these
you know crazy ass fight sequences and yeah like
the way she ultimately takes the
predator down i was like you know what
in this heightened little world i do believe this
i do believe that after all she's learned and with
that edge of figuring out that the helmet is the
crucial bit those targeting lasers are the crucial
bit if she can co-opt that and she can trap him
and she can you know use all of her other skills
if she can make herself invisible and i love that
too they faked us out with the mud she takes the
um orange tutsia i think they call it you know
the flower that makes your blood all cold and
of course i mean that's a bit of an action-moving
moment because she's not like convulsing but you
know who knows maybe she's been micro dosing very
often up until that point to build up a tolerance
um but yeah like you know she steps aside as the
guy who walks up to the really horrible nasty
trapper guy and uh and yeah it's like she
uses her original plan she lures him out
with the bait and then she uses the gun the gun
finally works and i love that too like the guns
rarely amount to much they do a couple
times but you can't like that one guy
with the ricochet like killing himself basically
um and then you know not obviously uh taking
the shot at the back of the predator's head
but like yeah the way they earn her taking
him down at the end at least to me felt very
well assembled and very well acted and very
well conceived from a story standpoint because
yeah you are watching two budding hunters learn
and one is obviously at an advantage and knows
a lot more and is you know the odds are stacked
in one side's favor at the beginning obviously but
the way they went about you know making that story
uh you know come together and making her you
know sort of this triumphant figure by the end
i i really enjoyed it and i felt like it was very
much earned and i liked the way that they took
a few different kinds of movie here you know
you have your predator movie your action horror
monster movie but you also have you know like i
said i think early on in the reaction like when
you dip out of that and you just go back to
life in the camp for a little while or life
is there on this hunt you really get pulled into
that stuff too and the movie cares just as much
about that stuff and knows how to make that
stuff just as engaging from a character level
but also as engaging from just an action from
an intensity level that yeah like all the pieces
are interesting and all the pieces are just the
right amount nothing really outstays its welcome
nothing feels too brief to me like this was a slam
dunk like like this is all that it needed to be
and and all the right kinds of more as far as
i'm concerned so i had a blast with this if you
couldn't tell leave me your thoughts i would love
to hear what you guys thought of this i hope you
guys enjoyed watching along with me and uh yeah
we will catch you for more uh movie reactions
going forward this is a lot of fun and uh yeah
sound off in the comments like and subscribe
and all that good stuff and i'll catch you on
the next one much love and as always cheers